字幕: daisaku harasaki
校正: Maki Sugimoto
はい 皆さん おはよう！
（客席）おはよう！
さっきね おやすみ（という歌が）
かかったからね （笑）
元気出していきましょう
はい 私を突き動かしたものは何？
というのでですね
お話したいと思います
私ね こうやってカッコよく
走っているんですよ
43歳の記念にですね
撮ってもらった写真なんですけど
なんと実は 30年間 僕は走ってないんです
その話を ちょっとしようと思います
私は10歳の時 交通事故で
足を失くしました
輸血を６リッターぐらいやって
大きな手術を何度も何度もやりました
そしてその後 社会人になり
まあ大学も出て
現在鹿児島で薬剤師をしています
そして２人の子供がいます
「らいた」と「こゆき」っていうんですけど
こゆきと 公園に行くんですよ
そしたらですね
「お父さん 来て 来て」と言うんですね
そしたらですね お兄ちゃんの方が
「お父さん 義足だから追いつけないの」
って言うんですよね
「なんだよ」と —
親の意地としては （笑）
沸々と なんか「追いついてやろうじゃないの」
って思うんですよね
子供の成長に合わせて
自分も成長したいって思えるわけですね
その後 だんだん色んなことを考えてて
「走るとは？」て考えるようになりました
「どうやって走るかな？」
って考えてですね
一番簡単なのは
「できる人を真似る」ですね
友人の安武君っています
医学部で陸上部にいました
TEDxKagoshimaUの
オーガナイザーでもあります
彼にですね お願いして
「陸上部の練習ちょっと付き合わせてよ」
って入って行ったんですね
それがこの 陸上部の感じですね
色々 こう観察しました
彼らの走りのですね
ピッチだとかストライド 着地点
スタートのしかた 加速のしかた
練習のしかた いろんなものを観察してて
だんだん分かってきたんですよ
「つまり飛べばいいのか」
って思ったんですね
小さい棒高跳び — 分かります？
ちょっとイメージ
してもらうと分かるんですけど
棒をつい立てて 前に出る —
これを連続すれば 走ってるように
見えるじゃんと思ったんです
これをですね 実践してみたらですね
「あれ？なんとなく走れたじゃん」と
自分の中で感覚があったんですけど
それがこの動画です
なんとなくですね なんとなく…
でもまだまだ ほぼ早歩きの状態です
これちょっと 良いんじゃないかなと思って
まあ日本中の 色んな情報を集めてですね
義足を扱っているところから
ちょっと貸してよと言って
お取り寄せしまして
試し履きを色々しました
鹿児島ではですね 実は
私は唯一の義足アスリートでですね
装具屋さんが扱ったことがないんですよ
スポーツ義足を
だからもう 試行錯誤で
ここ このぐらいの長さじゃない？とか
沈み込んだとき このぐらいの
長さじゃないと駄目だよねとか
そういうのを話し合いながらですね
作って行きました
で これ次の動画ですね
一番最初に走った時の動画です
まだまだね これ バネが
弱いんですよ — 緩いんですよ
柔らかくて 沈んで行くんで
スピードは全然出ないです
しかも
こう前の方について 走ろうとするので
ちょっとイメージしてもらうと
わかるんですけど
前に着いたら 後ろに跳ぶんですよ
（笑）
わかります？アスリートって
この恐怖と戦うんですよ
バネを後ろにつかないと
前に飛ばないんですよ
この感覚を磨いていきます
するとだんだん早くなります
音がかわるでしょ
（義足で走る足音）
だんだん早くなったんですよ
これでコツをつかんできたんで
体育館で息子たちといっしょに
跳躍力つけるために
縄跳びしたりですね
簡単な駆けっこしたりしたんですよ
なんとここで大発見がありました
なんだと思います？
凄いですよ
同じフォームで走ってるんです
（笑）
凄くないですか？
もうびっくりしましたよ
この瞬間の写真
レンタル品から自分専用を買いました
１本60万円くらいします
福祉では（助成金が）でないからですね
大金叩いて買ってきました
それをつけて練習をして
練習風景
グラウンドを走っているところですけど
これ息子と これ娘と
だんだん追いついてるんですよ
追いついたら 何て言われたと思います？
何て言われたと思います？
「ずるい」って言われたんですよ
（笑）
「お父さん それ着けてるから
速いんじゃん！」ていう
ちょっとまてと
「義足つけてるから追いつけない」
って言ってたよね
「義足つけてるから追いつける」っていう
見方を こどもたちの視点を
変えることができたんですよ
彼らの成長と僕の成長
これが交わった瞬間に僕は立会えて
親としては最高の瞬間でした
その後も陸上選手のトレーニングに
いろいろ参加させていただいて
大分とかのパラの陸上選手権とか
出させていただいて
記録が出ないんですけど
幸せ感は感じてました
全然だんぜんのビリでした
でもですね
30年間走ることの喜びに
気づかなかった
どこでこの喜びに気づいたんだろうと
思ったんですね
最初に動画流れましたね
デレク・シバースさんの
「社会運動はどうやって起こすか」
この動画に昔 感銘を受けた僕たちはですね
例のリーダーシップのように
フォロワーにお互いがなるような
コミュニティを作ったら
面白いんじゃないの？って言ってですね
鹿児島でコミュニティをつくりました
「いづろベース」っていいます
互いにちょっとおもしろいこと
やってみたかったら
乗っかりあおうぜってだけの会です
いろんなことをやりました
量産型ザクって知ってますかね？
量産型ザク
プラモ屋にいくと平積みになってるんですけど
あいつらかわいそうだから
ぜんぶつくってやろうぜって
買い占めてですね 作ってみたりですね
（笑）
宝塚のOGをお寺にお呼びして
「おてらづか」っていう（笑）
冗談が言いたいがための
イベントを企画してですね
あとは朝からヨガをまじめにやってみたり
ジャズシンガーとタップダンサーを
お茶屋さんでライブさせてみたりですね
畑でなんかいろいろ やってみたりですね
あと「24時間テレビ」みたいな
Tシャツきてキャンプしてたら
なんか勘違いされるんじゃないの
と言いながらキャンプしてみたりですね
いろんなことやりました
けっこう面白いイベントを
やっていったんですけど
そのなかの一つ
かみずるこう君っての（友達）がいて
彼がですね「夜中に走るコミュニティ
カルチャーを作りたいよね」なんて言うんですね
僕ね 救護班として
このミッドナイトランナーズ
鹿児島ってのがあったんで
救護班として参加しました
このコミュニティはですね
早く走ることが目的ではなくて
コミュニケーションをとることが目的
走るってキーワードと
夜中ってキーワードで
このふたつに敏感な層があつまれば
絶対面白いことあるんじゃないの
なんていいながら
やりました
すごい人数が参加しました
合計で400人
深夜12時に走って
６キロですね
途中 警察に呼びとめられる
シーンもありました（笑）
ちょっと規模を小さめにして続けてます
救護班だった私も
いつか一緒に走りたいなぁって
やっぱり思うわけですよ
そして走りました
はい20代女子を追いかける
40代の絵です（笑）
犯罪ですね（笑）
このコミュニティが僕に与えてくれたもの
それは「走ってもいいよ」っていう承認でした
振り返ると
承認のなかで小さな問いがうまれて
それが連鎖を起こして
僕は実行に至りました
走るとは「どのように」
「なぜ」走るのか
これをこういろんな問いが
ループしながら私を育ててくれました
学ばせてくれました
そしてコミュニティ、家族
これはですね
まるで触媒のように
私の思いをドライブしてくれたんです
そして共に成長するシーンも
多々ありました
道具でもなければ 技術でもなく
繋がりから生まれるものに
突き動かされました
どうせ足がないから
走る体力 技術なんてないし
実はいろいろ人生でも 断ってきました
走れないから俺 無理
ちょっとそれ 体力的に無理だわとか
それはできないって言って
いろんなのを断ってきました
人生いろいろ損をしました
でも それは取り返せないけど
今からでも取り返すことは
できるわけですね
30年間 この気づかなかった呪いを
どうにか払拭して
私は走ることができました
そんな呪いから脱出するには
できることはひとつです
ワクワクしたら道具や技術がなくてもいいです
そのコミュニティに
（義足で地面を蹴る音）
片足を突っ込んでください
そしたら ありたい自分が見えてきます
現実の自分も見えます
そこから生まれる問いがあります
そのギャップを埋めるのが
物なのか スキルなのか
あとはそこを埋める
行動をするだけですね
何が自分を突き動かすのか
それは人との繋がりと
問い続けることです
ありがとうございました